唉，你知道嗎？我最近看到一則新聞，關於三立電視台把台灣的「辦桌」文化變成實境秀，叫做《請世界吃桌》。你知道嗎，這節目在社群上的瀏覽量已經破億了耶，每週還有百萬點閱。
辦桌喔？台灣的辦桌文化，老實說，光聽起來就覺得很在地，但要怎麼變成國際化的實境秀？這點其實讓我蠻懷疑的。電視台不是都在努力跟國際OTT平台競爭嗎，怎麼會去碰這種感覺有點「土」的題材？
這就是它出乎意料的地方啊！原文裡提到，三立以前都是「自產自銷」的模式，現在他們反而選擇跟外部的麗群影視合作，而且節目規模從本來的國內實境秀，升級到去雪梨歌劇院、紐約時報廣場、熊本城辦桌。
等等，這裡我有疑問。你說規模大升級，那不是代表製作成本會飆高嗎？電視台現在還要投入大筆資金去拍這種節目，成本划算嗎？這模式撐得久嗎？
這點其實就是他們創新之處。三立這次扮演的角色，很像新創圈的「加速器」和「天使投資人」。節目部內容營運長王淑娟有提到，他們幫製作公司籌資，還把以前累積三十年的產銷經驗拿出來，幫忙規劃商業模式和行銷。
聽起來像是把影視製作變成一個投資案來操作？那他們的「財務評估報告」怎麼說服投資方的？創意這種東西很難量化耶。
原文有寫到，三立做了一份很詳盡的財務損益表。它不僅包含傳統的廣告、冠名收入，還把版權銷售、周邊商品、藝人經紀、線下實體活動，甚至YouTube流量分潤這些長尾效應都算進去。他們用這種「內容價值」轉化成「商業模式」的精算系統，讓投資方更有信心。
哦，把內容當成一個可以量化的長期投資標的來看待，這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字，像社群瀏覽逼近一億，OTT平台也拿了雙料冠軍。不過，光靠這些就能讓節目爆紅嗎？現在社群流量這麼難掌握。
這點他們也跟一般做法不同。傳統電視台的行銷是節目拍完才宣傳，但《請世界吃桌》是「產銷合一」，早在開拍半年前，業務、行銷部門就已經加入討論了。他們在海外拍攝的時候，就已經規劃好幾十支短影音，提早發佈在社群上。
提早八個月就開始佈局社群喔？這就像店面都還沒開，外面就已經大排長龍了，這比很多新創公司還會玩。那這樣做的效果如何？
效果很不錯。像那個「紐約時報廣場預告」跟「洗碗花絮」，在節目開播前就衝破百萬觀看。林鶴明就說，這讓節目正式開播前的臉書粉絲就破十萬，還帶動首播收視率暴增到原時段的七倍。
蠻厲害的，如果我是小餐廳老闆，可能也可以學學這種模式。像我新菜單還沒出來，是不是可以先拍一些製作花絮、主廚故事，提早一個月在社群上鋪梗？
對啊，這就是我們可以學的地方。你甚至可以找一些美食KOL提早試吃，讓他們發布短影音，就像他們找千千這種自帶流量的KOL一樣。然後，別只把雞蛋放在一個籃子裡，多平台排播也很重要。
多平台排播？你是說，把節目放到不同平台？
是的，三立這次除了在自己的台灣台首播，隔天還在華視二播、緯來三播，再擴及國內各大OTT平台跟YouTube。這可以讓不同年齡層、不同習慣的觀眾都能看到，也保障了廣告客戶的曝光。這有點像我們平常工作，一個專案成果，不只在內部報告，也要多方管道跟客戶、合作夥伴分享，擴大影響力。
嗯，聽起來這些策略都很有系統性。不過，回到最初的質疑，一個辦桌文化，怎麼能持續發燒？它會不會只是一時的熱潮？
原文有提到，節目現在不只社群熱度高，連實體辦桌活動，即使每人席位定價上千元，三十桌名額還是「秒殺」。甚至有世界各地的台僑社團主動聯繫，願意贊助並邀請團隊去辦第二季。這顯示了IP的長尾效應還在發酵，它不只是個節目，還變成了一個可以延續的文化交流平台。
所以這不只是一個節目，更是一個品牌或是一個文化的IP。這對我來說，如果把我的產品或服務，也試著用這種方式去「包裝」，去讓它成為一個不只是功能的產品，而是一個能跟消費者產生連結的文化符號，或許就有機會走得更遠。
嗯，我覺得這案例，好像也提醒了我們，即使是再傳統的在地文化，只要找到對的商業模式和行銷手法，也能突破既有框架，走向國際市場，甚至變成一個有長期投資潛力的IP。